si juan antonio también conocido como
tony hernández ha sido condenado y aquí
en la corte federal del distrito sur de
nueva york a 30 años de prisión y aún a
cadena perpetua por cuatro cargos
relacionados con narcotráfico y posesión
de armas además el juez kevin casa el
encargado de esta causa también lo ha
sentenciado al pago de 138 millones y
medio de dólares
el abogado de tony hernández asegura que
este juicio que se celebró ya en octubre
de 2019 correspondió a cuestiones
políticas y tony hernández le ha dicho
al juez que no ha visto respetados sus
derechos la respuesta del juez ha sido
clara los derechos del condenado han
sido respetados en todo momento y además
ha dicho el juez kevin castel que se
trata de una cadena perpetua muy bien
merecida por 12 años relacionados con el
tráfico de drogas ahora la parte del
condenado tiene la opción de apelar la
sentencia a algo que se espera que hagan
próximamente los abogados
de tony hernández eso sí el juez le ha
dicho que en el tiempo en prisión
aproveché para reflexionar sobre lo que
ha hecho y a ver si puede hacer algo
bueno
por su país y por su familia recordemos
que el juicio de la sentencia que se ha
leído hoy tuvo lugar ya en octubre del
2019 y la lectura de esta sentencia se
ha en varias ocasiones cuando
por fin hoy la hemos podido conocer esos
30 años de prisión más cadena perpetua
obviamente este segundo esta segunda
condena anula a la primera